je vous posais une question chacun doit
tout vous jouez également chiffres
chaque bonne réponse devant un point il
y aura des questions pendant une minute
trente commencer par questions à la fin
des 2 minutes 30 les trois qui auront le
moins de points sont éliminés d'accord
at ensuite on fera plusieurs tours
attention à ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
une minute trente christian top donc
quelle ville français se trouve la cité
de l'espace à toulouse
bien qu'elle est l'impératif du magal et
l'impératif du verre de peindre à la
deuxième personne du pluriel vous merci
au nom porte le siège de la police
londonienne
je passe scotland yard
avec quel chanteur carole fredericks et
michael jones dont il formait un trio
qu'un jacques goldman oui sous quelle
titre français connaîtront le film
vertigo d'alfred hitchcock
merci airbags sueurs froides dans quelle
ville se déroule chaque année le
festival interceltique à bandeau non
laurent groupe jim morrison est tel
qu'ils le chanteur des doors c'est
terminé elles n'ont porte le bateau de
théodore géricault par le radeau le
radeau bien sûr combien de mercenaires
combattant aux côtés de yul brynner en
1960 belle et cette marque mercenaires
dont elle avait 6 mai alors qu'elle
avait six doit-on le personnage de boule
de suif aux passants oui dans quel jeu
télévisé rené barjavel et miron ton
pyramide bien à quels mouvements
littéraires sont associés ronsard et du
bellay et romantique
la pléiade tel est le nom du joueur de
football qui a été l'objet du plus gros
transfert entre deux clubs en 2017
neymar oui où le général de gaulle
prononce-t-il son fameux je vous ai
compris
berlin alger un golf
déterminé à golf artistique sur le green
à potter mais quelle couleur sur les
gens qui j'ose oui
c'est vous vous dites qu'ils sont nuls
alors il n'en restera qu'un christian
deux points et bien je vous le dis on
enlève on enlève et ben est bon on
enlève tous ceux qui ont géré au moins
terminer tout ce que 0 sont éliminés les
arrange personne que nous on n'a eu
qu'une oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas
grave ça barrick évacués de la journée
gilbert mathieu ouellette à bordeaux
allait signifier ce bar la loupe et si
on n'y va pas jaloux benjamin hochart
soit éliminé est-ce que vous pouvez
mettre tout gagné limitée déchire et
s'il vous plaît deuxième manche
attention est-ce que vous êtes prêts
christian une minute trente
c'est parti quel genre d'animal et le
silure un poisson-chat oui combien des
toiles qu'on porte le drapeau américain
51 50 quel est le prénom de la fiancée
de popeye open président hu est
accuellie vent la comai attin de signes
de feu en astrologie et 6 à quel terme d
une partie nulle aux échecs
par quel terme désigne une partie nulle
n'étaient pas très bonnes réponses à
quelques donateurs non non mais t'as dit
quoi abattre dans pattes avant du
compositeur dont on la célèbre
chevauchée des walkyries reiner c'est
exactement ce que fait la mante
religieuse après l'accouplement elle
manche quelques efforts le bagdad
demeurent bonnes réponses aux usa quelle
est la principale base de lancement
d'engins spatiaux
cap canaveral tient qu'à la berd et râle
c'est bien joué et l'auteur de la
critique de la raison pure rousseau par
emmanuel kant valaisan michel mr n'est
pas éliminé et ça continue oui parce
qu'elle est la monnaie officielle du
canada piano dollars exactement dans
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre qui
incarne numérobis jamel debbouze oui à
quel écrivain doit-on les mémoires
d'outre-tombe beau châteaubriant combien
de membres composé le groupe téléphone
quatre exactement au rugby quel nom
porte de le fait de marquer en
aplatissant le ballon à à une mêlée
sous quel nom est plus connue l'acide
désoxyribonucléique dans l
sous quel nom est plus connue est la
cible des actions il a demandé l'adn
très bonnes réponses
avoir gagné c'est christian qui est en
finale inscription aux halles est en
finale contre moi et afoula là encore
une position alors qu'il s'en va mener
une enveloppe parce qu'il va avoir une
question venait à côté de moi tous les
champs je rappelle le dit de questions
le maître 2001 on peut être coupée à
tout moment vous allez vous poser une
question bassin vous allez poser
question vous répondez pas tout de suite
si je réponds je suis champion d'accord
si vous ne répondez pas vous n'êtes pas
champion c'est elle perce de l'été
historique et habiter à paris aux trois
lances enlèvement n'auriez monory à
paris au 366 rue saint-honoré attendent
at on dit quelles personnalités
historiques à habiter à paris au 366 rue
saint-honoré alors juste un chamakh à
staline rodez iii la question mais sorti
de la tl personnalités historiques et
habiter à paris y croit 166 rue
saint-honoré
alors alors christian n'est pas dupe bon
alors que je pense alors je sais qui non
mais moi je sais je sais que je sais que
c'est pas dans ton quoi toi quand elle
même humour je pense que c'est
robespierre adéquat on espère break et
c'est la bonne